[Musique]
jeudi
je suis rentré chez moi john jude trouvé
c'est marrant d'avoir peur des fois
c'est grave c'est qu'une peluche et
c'est une telle violence
je comprends que le comportement des jo
de fils vous inquiétez je vous conseille
de lui trouver un endroit où ils se
sentent en sécurité de toute urgence
je pense que ça lui ferait du bien et à
nous aussi
oh la vache regardez moi ce truc ça doit
être le bâtiment principal
tu viens à jude
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on dirait que cette poupée a été cassé
et qu'on a recollé les morceaux qui est
ce charmant garçon brahms de tu seras
nom pareil il me l'a dit me racontent
plein de choses ça va je trouve tout ça
un petit peu flippant c'est lui brahms
ton nouvel ami vous parlez de quoi tous
les deux les autres familles avec qui il
a vécu
tu veux lui enlever sa coupe et oui au
début on entend un murmure quelque chose
lui arrive
il savait que votre fils le trouverez
[Musique]
je t'aime maman je t'aime aussi
[Applaudissements]
à